étrangères
[Musique]
Technologies les algorithmes qui alimentent
la plate-forme Facebook, y compris par
exemple la fonction de recommandation la fonction de fil d'
actualité de
nouvelles preuves provenant de
documents internes de Facebook montrent que ce
ne sont pas des technologies neutres en fait elles
priorisent et promeuvent et amplifient les
plus nocifs  types de contenu et cette
enquête montre que cela incluait l'
incitation à la violence et à la haine
contre les rohingyas
étrangers
[Musique]
merci
et nous disons que non seulement Facebook
doit un recours aux communautés qu'il
a lésées, mais nous appelons également les
gouvernements  pour freiner efficacement les
entreprises comme Facebook qui alimentent
les atteintes aux droits humains à travers le monde avec
ces modèles commerciaux destructeurs
[Musique]